[Musique]
c'est du snobisme
je sais pas je suis déjà venu en France
5 ou 6 fois et maintenant on dirait que
les Français ont vraiment envie de rire
il y a plein de trucs vulgaires dans
l'eau chaude mais comme je suis un clown
ça traite de choses que tout le monde
fait le roter péter et faire l'amour
et tout le monde se marre pendant tout
le spectacle oui c'est super moi aussi
je me barre je suis pas vraiment
beaucoup de plaisir si je pouvais rester
plus longtemps je resterai encore un an
j'ai d'autres engagements pour cette
on Israël à Moscou au Canada dans le
monde entier quoi ouais sauf en Amérique
partout sauf en Amérique
je sais pas les Américains sont trop
jeunes
enfin pas pour moi
parle-moi de toi c'est vrai que quand tu
avais 20h tu vendais de l'herbe ouais
j'étais paysagiste professionnel un
paysagiste
d'ailleurs à des trois j'ai encore un
terrain de golf
[Musique]
Berg timothyley
tout à fait
et après tu as décidé de devenir un
marginal quoi j'ai jamais arrêté de
chercher quelque chose dans ma vie la
vie c'est important c'est une valeur
dans les années 60 quand je prenais de
l'acide et que je fumais de l'herbe je
suis en vendais
quoi c'est ça
de l'herbe et puis tu t'es aperçu que
c'était pas un bon style de vie quoi
tu t'es pas heureux je savais plein
d'argent une grosse voiture je les
filles et j'étais souvent
et ça c'est pas vivre
j'ai décidé que la seule chose à faire
c'était d'essayer d'aider les gens comme
il dit par le riz c'est une sorte de
thérapie thérapie qui est très
importante très simple très important
c'est vrai que tu as décidé de devenir
marginal après avoir lu un bouquin
d'offenski qui s'appelle forfait
et qu'est-ce qui pouvait raconter pour
avoir une telle influence sur toi ou je
pense qu'il racontait l'histoire d'un
mec un pays gonfiev qui avait une école
ici à Fontainebleau c'est un des très
très nombreux livres écrits sur la
conscience de soi sur la connaissance
[Musique]
c'est une chose qui m'a fait prendre
conscience comment m'aider moi-même
conscience regardez soi-même les clowns
sont un peu un reflet un reflet des gens
beaucoup de gens disent que les clowns
sont tristes mais s'ils ont cette
impatience parce que les clowns montrent
aux gens de quoi ils ont l'air et les
gens sont tristes
on décide pas de devenir clown on décide
plutôt d'aller en ashram non
c'est la manière de vivre dans la
civilisation occidentale
mais le reste ça fait partie de la
civilisation orientale
c'est une manière de mieux appréhender
la civilisation
occidentale Jean rumin les affaires
ils n'ont pas besoin d'avoir un nez
rouge il y a des interviews des femmes
clowns des clowns des bouchers
[Musique]
n'aiment pas mais il y a toujours
quelque chose qui les aime
généralement à la sortie si vous allez à
mon spectacle la partie importante du
show c'est quand c'est terminé quand tu
es venu chez un autre chose je n'étais
pas à la sortie mais d'habitude je suis
à la sortie tous les soirs et quand les
gens sortent je regarde mon visage je
dis aux gens
pendant mon spectacle il y a une chose
que je voudrais pouvoir vous donner
je voudrais que vous soyez à ma place
comme ça pourriez voir vos visages
quand je regarde le public les gens sont
comme ça c'est un moment d'espoir un
moment de rigolade de relaxation même si
c'est grossier même si c'est classé
c'est sexy c'est c'est fou tu les
frappes oui j'ai pas possible ils
adorent ça leur balance des œufs sur la
gueule si vous venez me voir mettez un
appel si vous êtes au premier
ça tu reviens toujours en France
j'adore la France c'est un pays super en
ce moment je suis déjà venu mais en ce
moment les gens vraiment envie de rien
je sais pas je sais pas pourquoi c'est
parce qu'ils ont pu personne pour les
faire marrer maintenant en plus il y a
les élections présidentielles
de rigoler la comédie à la politique
se proches bien des points qu'est-ce que
tu dirais aux Français avant qu'ils
aillent voter pour le prochain président
[Musique]
je regarde de plus près
une dernière chose chanson que j'ai
écrite pour les sourds c'est un
classique mais vu différemment
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu